it is a big adrenaline rush just being
on the field seeing all those people who
you would think it makes you nervous but
it excites you even when soon as I give
the band everybody stops looking at the
football game they cut the cameras on
and eyes are on you
those lights flash and cameras watch him
in the crowd go crazy is the Jay safe
style it's not something that you just
seen every single day my name is Kayla
Gordon I'm captain of the press and Jay
says here at Jackson State University
we're very null for j-setting j-setting
is a complex style it's a mixture of
acrobatics and African style with a
little bit of jazz a lot of people
compare us to Jimmy's because we have a
lot of studs in our moves that most
other teams don't have some of our
signature moves would definitely be a
salt and pepper it's kind of what we
throw our arms back and forth another
signature March we have is the tiptoe
you're pulling your pelvis back and
forth and your arms are just coming
straight up and down when Jay say walk
you're going to see our hips the most
look like they find a pop out looking
and that's kind of just popping back and
forth at a very fast pace Jay setting is
a word that stemmed here from Jackson
State University all the way back in
1971 my name is Gloria Tatum I am the
founder of the Alumni Jay set
organization I am also an original
legendary princey Jason the jay sets
were originally majorettes they were
girls that would march in front of the
band but they held the turns
surely militant Blakeley the sponsor at
that particular time had this great idea
to bring the Jay sets to be dancers and
so Jay City was born
[Music]
our training and practices is different
from other dance teams we run two miles
on the 18 minutes every single day we
practice Monday through Friday and then
Saturday in the game so out of a
seven-day week you with the Jason six of
those days Vantage I say is very
competitive
we do have cuts each week for a game
your spot is not guarantee on the field
you're gonna work hard for it even if
you're a new girl or an old girl because
all girls can get cut too even though
you've been on the team for two or three
years you can get cut as well it's set
up to make you work even harder
[Music]
j-setting has become very influential in
different communities as far as the
LGBTQ community as far as choreographers
knowing that a lot of people watch us
and knowing that we influenced a lot of
people like seeing Beyonce even seen
Sierra do like a couple of our moves
it's very excited cuz it's letting you
know the big people like that are really
watching you
we made a star oh and we made a name for
ourselves and a lot of people know us
and respect us from that
you